THE FORMER PANTHER ANNA PLAYED
WELCOME TO THE
SKATERS LIKE A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
TO CENTER.
YLONEN, DREW AL'S FIRST SHOT ON
HAS TIED THE GAME AT ONE.
>> Randy: TIMEMEOF THESE PLAYER
OBVIOUSLY KNOW, YOU PLAYED IN
THE LEAGUE IN
GOAL.COME IN TWO
GAMES SINCE RETURNING, AND HE
PICKS UP A LOOSE PUCK HERE.
MARCIT AHEAD.
NANAIMO TIES UP RINEHART AND
ICE, SCOOPED UP
BY MARCHMENT.
FLIP OUT TO CENTER.
LUNDELL CATCHES UP TO IT AT THE
MONTREAL  LINE.
HORNQVIST PUT IT BEIT 12 AND
6 FOR A TOTAL OF 18.
RINEHART HAS BEEN PRETTY GOOD
SO FAR HERE TONIGHT.
WON THAT LAST DRAW IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
FAFORMER
TEAMMATE.
THEY ARE CHATTING IT UP,
MONTEMBEAULT AND VATRANO TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT
SUZUKI.
LEAD PASS ON  PUCK.
IT'S FOUR ON FOUR SO YOU KNOW
PASS.
THAT'S BROKEN.
REINHART IN OCKED.
HARVEY-PINARD CLEARS THE
PANTHER LINE, PICKED UP BY
THEY HAVE
INTERMISSION.
>> Steve: ORDER ON THAT FLA
LIVE
GOT TWO. EAD!
THEY'VE GOT THE LEAD . NOW
THE
VAVAADJUSTMENTS
IN THAT SECOND PERIOD IN THEIR
DEFENSIVE ZONE COVERAGE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A CLIP
WHERE THE PANTHERS ARE STUCK IN
THE NET.
LOOK AT GOOD COVERAGE,
EVERYBODY SHIFTS OVER.
THERE E DUKE
CHANTS GO UP.
HE TRIES THE BACK PASS THAT'S
STOLEN AWAY.
RNQVIST.
AND THIS COMES ALL THE FATE M.O
BENNETT AND WEEGAR WERE THERE I
THCHEESE  DEPARTMENT WITH